In the last video we defined
our random variable x as the
number of heads we get after
flipping a coin five times,
and it's a fair coin.
And then we figured out the
different probabilities that
the random variable could
take on different values.
Let me rewrite them all here.
The probability that we
get exactly one head or
zero heads-- actually,
let's start there.
The probability we get zero
heads, and that's the same
thing as getting five tails--
we figured out was 1 out of 32.
The probability of getting
1 head we figured
out was 5 over 32.
The probability of getting 2
heads-- probability that our
random variable is equal
to 2, what was that?
I think it was 10/32.
Yeah, it was 10/32 or 5/16.
10/32 which is equal to 5/16.
The probability that we get
three heads, that was actually
equal to the same thing, 10/32
which is equal to 5/16 .
And that made sense because
the probability of getting 3
heads is the same thing as a
probability of getting 2 tails.
And the probability of getting
2 tails should really be the
same thing as the probability
of getting 2 heads.
And then finally, or almost
finally, the probability that
we get 4 heads, that was equal
to 5/32, which also makes sense
because the probability of
getting 4 heads is the same
thing as the probability
of getting 1 tail, right?
And 1 tail should be the same
thing as 1 head, so that's why
these numbers are the same.
And then finally, the
probability that we get all 5
heads, which is the same thing
as getting no tails, is 1/32.
The probability of no tails
is the same thing as the
probability as no heads.
So let's draw this.
Let's draw our probability
distribution.
OK, let me draw the x-axis.
That's not thick enough.
I'll do it a different color.
All right, and just let
me try draw the y-axis.
Almost there.
All right, so what are the
different values that we care
about for our random variable?
Notice, these are all
discreet values.
They're all particular finite
numbers that we care that our
random variable can take on.
And that was actually a
function of our definition of
the random variable, right?
This random variable, number of
heads after 5 flips-- you can't
have an infinite number
of values here.
Your value can either be 0
through 5, and it can't
be a non-integer even.
But the important thing to
realize that there's a finite
number of values that this
random variable can take on and
that's why we have a discreet
probably distribution.
All right, so the probability
that it takes on-- let me just
draw 0, 1, 2, 3, 4, and 5.
This is for our
random variable, x.
So this is the number
of heads in 5 trials.
Let me draw the
high points first.
So let's see, the high points
are-- they're all right there.
10/32.
That's the probability of 2
and 3 and they're the same.
Let me draw little bar graph.
So 2 and 3; let's just say that
this is 10/32 right there.
I'll draw them the highest
because those are
the highest values.
2 and 3 both hit 10/32.
Actually, let me draw it
a little differently.
Let me make it so they
touch each other.
So let's say 2 is there,
and then we draw 3.
And 3 is also there.
There you go.
All right, what's the
probability that you get 1?
That was 5/32, so
that's 1/2 of these.
These two should be
the same height.
So that's 5/32.
Should be like that.
That's the same thing
as getting 4 heads,
so that's like that.
Let's assume that
this 4 is down here.
The probability of
getting either 0 or
5 is the same thing.
That's 1.
So that's going to be
1/5 of this height.
So it's going to look
something like that.
Let's say this last
one is for 5.
The drawing is the
hardest part.
That's going to look
something like that.
All right, and so this is for 5
and this is for 4 right here.
And this right here
is 10/32 or 5/16.
This is 5/32.
And this right here is 1/32.
What I have just drawn is
a binomial probability
distribution.
It's a particular
instance of the binomial
probability distribution.
And actually, as you get to
kind of an infinite number of
values, and once we get to the
continuous, this'll approach
the famous bell curve that
you hear about where
things actually start
looking like a bell.
Or it'll start
looking like that.
And we'll do some-- maybe I'll
get Excel out and I'll do it
where I start saying-- instead
of saying, the number
of heads in 5 trials.
If I did this as the number of
heads in 5 million trials,
these bars would get very, very
close together and you'd start
seeing them approach this thing
that looks like a bell curve.
And this is a very
important distribution.
One, because it actually
describes a lot of
random processes.
But it's actually very
important to statistics
generally because a lot of
times in statistics you don't
know the underlying mechanism
that's generating your results
and you just assume that
there's just a bunch of
random stuff going on.
You just add up a bunch
of random events.
When you're adding up random
events that's like counting
the number of heads.
So you assume that a lot
of things have-- well,
in the discreet case, a
binomial distribution.
And then, in a few videos
from now I'll show you the
continuous cases, which is
the normal distribution.
And this is really important
to realize because sometimes
people make that assumption
about certain things and the
biggest one-- and this is
probably the most negative
repercussions, especially in
this type of financial
environment.
Well, they'll assume that some
process has a binomial or a
normal distribution where
it really doesn't.
Because if you assume that
something has a distribution
like this you start saying,
oh, well the probabilities at
these ends are really low.
But what if the distribution
is something like this?
And I'll do more work on this.
I don't want to get too
advanced too fast.
But the general idea, it's
really important to understand
the assumption you're making
when someone says, oh, we
assume it's a normal
distribution.
We assume it's a
binomial distribution.
But with that said, that's
a little bit of a nugget
of why this is important
going into the future.
But just to kind of review
a little more what we've
already studied, let's
think about this.
Why is this called a
binomial distribution?
Well, if you think about it,
when you flipped 5 coins or
when you had 5 flips of the
same coin-- each arrangement,
I'll pick an arbitrary
arrangement of heads and tails.
Each circumstance of heads and
tails, I guess I could call it.
You know, that's one
of them, 5 flips.
Each of these have exactly
a 1 in 32 probability.
In fact, there's exactly
32 ways I can draw some
combination of heads
and tails here.
So each of those have a
1 in 32 probability.
And what we essentially did in
the last video when we said,
OK, what was the probability
of getting exactly two heads?
We essentially said, OK, how
many of these circumstances, or
how many of these-- I guess we
could call it-- how many of
these permutations had 2 heads?
And we counted them up and we
said, 10 of them have 2 heads
and that's why the probability
was 10 out of 32.
And the way we figured
that out is for example,
if we said, 2 heads.
We said, OK, 1 of 5 flips could
be the first head, and then 1
of 4 flips could be
the second head.
And then we don't care about
order, so we don't care if flip
1 was a first head and flip two
was a second head or was
the other way around.
So we divide by 2, and we
said that this was the
same thing as 5 factorial.
Actually, let me do
it color coded.
This part is the same thing as
5 factorial over 3 factorial.
And then, that's actually the
same thing as 2 factorial
because 2 factorial
is 2 times 1.
So in general, let
me write this down.
The probability that x
equaled n-- and this is
for the x that I defined.
The random variable, the number
of heads I get in 5 flips of
the coin-- it was equal to 5
factorial divided
by n factorial.
In this case it was 2, 2 was n.
We said was the probability
that we get exactly 2 heads.
Times 5 minus 2 factorial.
And I encourage you to review
because it really is important
to get an intuitive
feel of this.
I encourage you to review
the videos I made in the
probability playlist on
binomial coefficients, and on
this flipping of coins type of
probability problems because I
go a little more in detail in
the actual intuition of this.
But if you watch those or if
you have a little bit of
experience with this, you
would recognize that this is
the binomial coefficient.
And actually, I even have a
video why it's called the
binomial because these
coefficients show up when you
actually multiply binomials.
Binomials are just things like
if I just have x plus why and I
start multiplying it by itself,
take it to different powers,
the coefficients of these tend
to be-- well, they are
the same as these.
And I give you a whole
video on why that-- well,
that's why that works.
And so this is why
it's even called the
binomial coefficient.
And why this is called the
binomial distribution.
But another way of writing
this, the shorthand
is 5 choose n.
And they say that because
what were we doing?
We said we had 5 flips and
we were choosing 2 of
the flips to be heads.
Or, in this case, we have 5
flips and we're choosing n
of the flips to be heads.
So this will tell you how many
of the different permutations
satisfy our condition.
And then we say, well,
what's the probability
of each of those?
It's times 1 out of 32.
So this is why it's called
a binomial distribution.
Each of the values of
probabilities for each of the
random variable values-- you
can figure them out by using
your binomial coefficients.
Anyway, I just realized
I'm out of time again.
And don't worry, I'm going to
do a couple of more examples
with this because I really want
you to get the hang of the
binomial distribution before we
move into the normal
distribution.
See you soon.